翻訳: Keisuke Yamashita
校正: Hiroko Kawano
私たちは今
少子高齢化による人口の減少や
それに伴うマーケットの縮小
あるいはITやデジタルの急激な発展に伴う
大きな変化の時代の中にいます
初めて直面するこのような変化を前に
不安を感じてしまうこともあります
でもここに一つの事実があります
私たち人類は20万年
ホモサピエンスになってからずっと
変わらぬこの身体で
今日まで生き続けています
変わらぬこの体と心で
みんなで知恵と力を寄せ合って
氷河期やあるいはペストや
あるいは戦争という
様々な困難を乗り超えて来ました
つまり今生きている私たちは誰もが
その内側に変化の時代を生き延びる
知恵と力を十分に持っているのです
もうこれで これからどんな
変化の時代が訪れても安心ですよね
おめでとうございます
（拍手）
まぁ 拍手も小さいですし
あまり実感がないのかなと思います
そこで今日は そんな私たちの中にある
「生きる知恵と力を引き出すアイデア」を
ご紹介させていただきたいと思います
私はこれまでチーム作りの
ワークショップをしてきました
なぜなら家庭でも会社でも
人間はどうやら チームを作って
生きるようにできているからです
その中で 分かったことがあります
ワークショップの会場で
「この中で誰かが困っている時に
手助けしてもいいと思う人？」と聞くと
９割以上の方が手を挙げてくれます
でも一方で
「この中で 自分が困っている時に
助けてくださいと言える人？」と聞くと
ぱらぱらっと手が挙がるだけなんですね
大体１割か 多くても２、３割ぐらいです
「昔はもっとみんな助け合っていたよ」と
よく話を聞きますが
実は今 問題なのは
人の役に立ちたいという思いを
持つ人が少ないことではなくって
「助けてください」と言える人が
少ないということなんです
つまり 私たちの
人の役に立ちたい思いというのは
今 圧倒的な受け手不足なんです
「助けてください」と言うのは
つまり
自分の弱みを表に出すと
いうことですよね
そこで 私が提案しているのが
「弱みを軸としたチーム作り」です
具体的には
３つのステップになります
チーム作りなので
まず何人かが集まります
そこでまず最初に
自分の弱みを発表します
例えば こんな感じですね
紙とかに書くと分りやすいと思います
こんにちは 湯川カナです
私はお金の計算が
ちょっと苦手です
これ 本当の話です —
これが 第１のステップです
次に 第２のステップです
それを聞いた人が
あるセリフを言います
ちょっと難しいかもしれないので
よく聞いてくださいね
いいですか？
「かわいー♪」です
じゃ 練習しますよ
いいですね？
私が自分の弱みを言います
皆さんは
ジェスチャー付きですよ —
「かわいー♪」と言ってくださいね
OK？
こんにちは
あの私 実はちょっと
お金の計算が苦手なんです
せーの
（会場）「かわいー♪」
ありがとうございます（笑）
このように
それがたとえどんな弱みであっても
「かわいー♪」と言ってください
最後に 第３のステップです
そんなチームメンバーの弱みに対して
何か自分ができることがないかな と
考えてください
この時に大切なことがあります
決してその人を
変えようとしないことです
間違っても弱みを克服させようなんて
思っちゃダメなんですよ
だって弱みは
「かわいー♪」ものだったでしょ？
例えば お金の計算が苦手だという
チームメンバーに対して
「お金の計算なら私がしてあげるよ」
と言う人がいるかも知れませんし
「じゃあ 私がお金を預かってあげる 」
と言う人がいるかも知れません
思えばこうやってこのように
税理士さんや公認会計士さん —
あるいは銀行っていう仕事が
生まれてるんですよね
たぶん 私と同じように
お金の計算が苦手な方が
たくさんいらっしゃったんだと思うんです
ひょっとしたら私と同じように
そのことに引け目を感じていた方も
いらっしゃるのかなと 思います
でも 今日からは胸を張っていましょう
だって 私たちの弱みのお陰で
この世にこんなにたくさんの仕事が
生まれているんですからね
先ほどからこういう風に
弱みとか強みと言っていますが
大事な前提があります
弱みとか強みというのは
関係性の中で決まるということです
例えば お金の計算が強くても
税理士さんほどじゃないかも知れない
英語が得意でも
旅先が英語圏じゃなかったら
どれ程役に立つか
分からないですよね
あるいは
すごく優秀なビジネスマンが
泣き止まない赤ちゃんを
あやすことができるかどうかっていうのは
ちょっと皆さん
想像しやすいかと思います
逆に 自分では思いもしなかったところが
強みになる と言うのもよくある話です
冒頭でお話ししたように
私たちは今
大きな変化の時代にいます
明日 あなたの中のどのような部分が
強みとなるかなんて
誰にも分かりません
ひょっとしたらそれは
今日は自分の弱みだと
思っているところかも知れません
ですので どのような関係性の中でも
丸ごとの自分を生き生きと発揮させる
ことができる様なチームを作ることが
とっても大切になるんです
私がこういう事を
考えるきっかけになったのが
スペインでの出産でした
私は言葉が一言も分からない
スペインに移住して
あいにく大してペラペラになる事もないまま
現地で出産をしました
大きなベビーカーを押して
エスカレータの無い地下鉄の階段の前で
こうやって独りたたずむ
言葉が不自由で
ついでにギックリ腰の私 —
それまでは
「みんなに迷惑かけちゃいけない」
「やっぱり一人で頑張らなくっちゃ」と
ずっとやってきたんですけど
さすがにもう
そんな余裕はありません
なので 思い切って声を上げました
「すみません 困っています」
ひょっとしたら 迷惑がられるんじゃ
ないかなと思ったんですけど
実際には通りすがる誰もが
笑顔で手助けしてくれました
「あぁ そうか！」 と
つくづく思いました
「助けてください」という
手助けしてもらったことに
「ありがとう」と感謝を伝える
その時に生まれるのは
両方とも笑顔だけなんです
もしもあの時 私が一人で
難しい顔をして頑張っていても
通路の一部を塞がれた通行人も
あるいは ベビーカーの中で
待たされ続ける赤ちゃんも
もちろん ギックリ腰の私だって
誰一人
幸せにはならないんですよね
ではここで
弱みを軸にしたチームと
強みを軸にしたチームの違いを
ちょっと考えてみたいと思います
もし仮に
現時点でのチームメンバーの
強みを軸としたチームを作るとします
すると どうなるでしょうか？
「これはあの人の仕事だから
もう任せとけばいいよね」
「これはあの人の強みだから
あの人の仕事のはずなのに
何でやらないんだろう？」
「私はこれが仕事だから
もうこれは私は 終わった」
「すみません あの〜
私 次 何したらいいんですか？」
こういう風に お互いを責め合ったり
誰かの指示を待つ 依存型のメンバーが
増える傾向があります
でもね 当然なんですよ
だって その時にみんなに
割り振られているのは
全体の中での こうあるべき自分や
こう期待されている自分なんですよね
誰かが勝手に決めた 現実の自分ではない
自分でプレイをしなきゃいけない
そんな状況で 自主的に考えて
判断して行動するなんて
でも 依存型のメンバーが多いというのは
チームとしては脆弱なものになります
一方で 弱みを軸にしたチームの場合は
どういうことが起こるでしょう？
実際に私は今 弱みを軸とした
強固なチームを作っています
メンバーは６人
みんな いわゆる 主婦の方たちです
私は本当にお金の計算が
苦手なんですけども
そんな私が一人で教育事業をもう一所懸命
四苦八苦やっているのを見た
元受講生の皆さんが
「あぁ これちょっと もう見ちゃいられない」
と言って 集まって来てくれました
で 私が示す大きなビジョンを前に
最初は「あー やっぱり 私なんて
そんなことはできません」て言ったり
「ごめんなさい
すごい一所懸命やってみたんですけど
やっぱりできなくって...
本当にごめんなさい」と
謝ってばっかりだったりしました
でも今は
「とりあえず 私これやってみます
やってみてダメだったら
みんなよろしくね」
という感じで
自主的に動くという文化ができました
今では 私が一番苦手だったお金の計算から
講座の企画 そして全体の事業の運営まで
みんなでチームでワイワイとやっています
その効果が
本当に意外なところに表れました
「このチームに関わってどう変わった？」
という話をしていた時のことです
みんながこういう風に 口ぐちに言いました
「最近子供から『お母さん あまり
怒らなくなったよね』と言われました」
あるいは「何かね 家にいて
イラっとすることが減ったし
夫との会話も増えたんです」
えっ!? よくよく聞いてみると
家庭でも何か問題が起こった時に
相手を責めたり
あるいは 自分を責めたりする前に
「あー じゃあこの状況で
今 私にできることは何かしら？」って
自主的に考える癖がついたことで
ご家族との関係もガラッと良好になった
ということでした
なぜこのような変化が
起こったのでしょうか？
最初は 自分に自信が無くって
謝ってばっかりだったメンバーに対して
私が言い続けたことがあります
「大丈夫 謝らなくていい
ダメだった時には みんなを信じて
みんなに委ねて！
一人で頑張るっていうのは
みんなを信じてないって事だからね」
その結果 何かがあっても
誰かが必ずフォローに入ってくれるという
温かな信頼感があるチームができました
そういうチームだから
失敗をしても大丈夫という感覚があります
失敗をしても大丈夫と思うから
チャレンジができる
チャレンジができるから
自分の可能性がどんどん広がります
チームの力って
所属するメンバーの力の総和 ー
それ以上にはならないと思っています
メンバーのそれぞれの力
それぞれの可能性が存分に広がり
それぞれの生きる知恵と力が
思いっきり発揮されるー
そういう主体的に動くチームだからこそ
どのような時代の変化にあっても
対応できる
朗らかで強固なチームとなるんです
で そんなチームのリーダーの私は
何をしているかというとですね
私はこのチームの中で
一番できない人です
「あそこら辺にみんなで行きたいよね」
という 大きなビジョンは示せるんですけど
本当に とにかくできないんですよ
なので みんなが面白がって
「あぁ これちょっとやってみます
私も苦手だけどカナさんよりは
できる気がするし」
あの 本当にそうなんです —
それで
「それにね 私
このチームでやってみたいんです」
そうやって笑顔で
どんどん引き受けてくれます
その結果 みんなが自主的に動く
朗らかで強固なチームが
勝手にできました
もしもチームのリーダーが
強くて力もあって
お金もあって何でもできるとしたら
もうチームって
そもそもいらないですよね？
みんなに支えてもらわなきゃいけない
リーダーだから
チームができる
私はそう考えています
で こういう話をしていると
絶対に聞かれるんですよ
「人の役に立ってばかりで
損じゃないですか？」とか
「嫌になりませんか？」
この質問にぴったりの答えが
チャップリンの言葉にありました
映画 『独裁者』のラストシーンです
「私たちはみな 誰かほかのひとを
助けたいと思っている
人間とは そういうものである」
人間とは
人の役に立ちたい生き物なんです
最後に一つ
思い出していただきたい光景があります
小さな子供ってお手伝いするのが
大好きじゃないですか？
何か食器を運んだり
物を取ってきたり
あるいは 肩を叩いてくれたり
大人が「あー何とかちゃんのお陰で
本当に助かった ありがとう」とお礼を言うと
満面の笑みを返します
あの充実感 あの喜び —
思い出してください
誰かの役に立つというのは
そのこと自体がとっても大きな喜びなんです
子供の場合
親が何かを頼むというのが
その子供の「誰かの役に立ちたい」
という思いを実現させました
その結果がこの笑顔です
最初にも言ったように
今 実際に人の役に立ちたい人
というのはいっぱいいます
そんな本質的にとっても優しくて
温かな心を持つ私たちの
「誰か人の役に立ちたい」と思う
人間性を目一杯 発揮できるように
どうか まずはあなたが
自分の弱みを出してください
ちょうど あの時 あなたの親御さんが
あなたにそういう機会を与えてくれたように
周りを活かして 自分も活かされる
朗らかで強固な人間の集団ー
その軸となるのは...
忘れないで下さいね
私たちそれぞれの
とっても「かわいー♪」弱みです
ありがとうございました
（拍手）